mesure scène puisqu'elle va aider au
rajeunissement du parc qui on voit bien
qu'en martinique
on a encore des vieux modèles qui
circulent et qui ont tendance à rejeter
des fumées
et puis pour nous dans le marché de
l'automobile
ça va être une vraie incentive pour
permettre aux martiniquais là de pouvoir
renouveler manière un petit peu plus
rapide un leur véhicule et un mois nos
collègues métropolitains nous ne sommes
pas sur ce côté nous avons l'habitude de
travailler sur stock nous n'avons pas
vendu de voitures ces derniers mois
certes mais nous n'en avait pas reçu non
plus puisque nous travaillons en kiosque
ça nous empêche pas néanmoins de on va
dire de stimuler le marché avec des
offres intéressantes pour les gens qui
se croient qu'il se soit dans une
musique de changer de véhicules viennent
nous voir encore de façon plus
enthousiaste je dirais mais on n'est pas
dans la situation de la métropole où on
affiche les moins 40 à moins 50% de
remise